la dev merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau tout le monde sait que vous êtes
un chanteur néerlandais adopté par les
français par la france auteur de
plusieurs tubes
ce que l'on sait moins en revanche c'est
que vous venez de composer votre
première musique de film
en effet c'est une nouvelle expérience
pour moi kg trouve extrêmement
enrichissant un passionnant j'espère
d'ailleurs que ce serait pas bon d'en
diffuser ce film ce film ça fait
l'esprit de famille est dans la scène
que vous allez voir on voit à jeu
télévisé qui pourrait se passer sur
notre chaîne où la famille qui est
l'héroïne du film constate avec surprise
que la petite fille lavage amine
manifeste une connaissance
extraordinaire de la vie et des oeuvres
complètes d'edf car il s'agit pour la
petite fille de gagner ce concours qui
lui permettra de sauver le cheval de sa
soeur aînée molle
ça va venir on va voir d'ailleurs dv le
héros de cette de ce concours qui est un
conte dernière introduction musicale c6
cécile si j'échoue wii qui écrit le
texte de cette chanson musiques et
paroles de we est l'année de création de
cette chanson il ya six ans a senti
formidable oeuvres à gauche que
l'approché toi jean paul les filles sont
les plus fortes dernière étape de ce jeu
le nom de la ville où dave a passé son
enfance moselle pineau la ricoh et oui
oui c'était très très bien bon alors là
attention cécile il faut faire beaucoup
mieux encore titre de la pièce
interprétée par dave au festival
d'avignon
on dit bien 8e question des pinault avec
qui dave est passé pour la première fois
en vedette à l'olympia annie partie on
retrouve assis cécile quel est le titre
avec lequel dave fut numéro un au japon
pouvoir oui oui oui
et enfin attention la dernière question
celle qui va vous départager
c'est ici que la partie se gagne ou se
perd le véritable nom de dave terre
nouvelle vague et bien sûr des élèves en
bac non alors le véritable sebha autre
c'est en effet très c'est un peu
compliqué sais pas mais la petite
desgagnés c'est une salle secrète vous
fait un petit rôle dans l'esprit de
famille mais vous allez faire un grand
rôle dans un autre film qui s'appelle la
grande foule et vous êtes très intéressé
par le cinéma
disons que je prends un petit peu comme
exemple
une grande exemple d'ailleurs d'aznavour
de charles aznavour j'aime je n'ai pas
du tout l'intention d'abandonner la
chanson c'est vraiment plus qu'une
passion pour moi mais comme lui ne
serait-ce que pour avoir sa carrière
internationale mais aussi je crois qu'il
a fait au moins une trentaine de films
donc un film par an comme ça si on veut
bien moi je veux bien et en france que
c'est difficile en effet y ait très peu
de chanteurs qui réussissent l'admet et
puis il y avait franck sinatra il ya eu
8 montant il ya eu du trombone avrillé
hub râle mais tous les autres chanteurs
qui ont voulu s'essayer au cinéma on
fait un film deux et puis ça a été fini
vous êtes ribes et ce à quoi
mais il ya un problème je crois de
l'imagination de venant du côté de
mettre en scène évidemment là ils
s'imaginent difficilement qu'on peut il
s'imagine déjà pas du tout qu'on sait
lire et écrire généralement et mettez en
scène de cinéma crois qu'on m'aide et
croit et qu'on a juste bons à mimer une
chanson comme je file à toute allure
mais on fait pas que ça dans la vie et
il ya maintenant un nez très grand 10
ans venant de d au moins des producteurs
distributeurs suite sûrement au film un
américain john travolta est encore que
personnellement j'aimerais pas
spécialement faire de films musicaux
mais plutôt des rôles de composition si
possible alors maintenant c'est que vous
savez lire et écrire
alors vous allez nous chanter une
chanson ce n'est d'ailleurs pas la
chanson du film
non parce que comme dans le film je vais
pas grand chose d'autre au moins ne pas
dévoiler cette séquence et chanter une
chanson qui concerne autre chose
d'actualité puisque on est dans une
forme d'actualités savall années de
l'enfance une chanson qui s'appelle
dommage et bien voilà d'ailleurs le
sujet véritable du film ce sont les
états d'âme de quatre jeunes filles
vis-à-vis de tous les problèmes de
l'adolescence et de l'enfance
une enfance
que ça
ce
de pente
enfance
le show
et
que l'on a
je
bonjour
tout le soleil
ça va
à
en france
bonjour
en
jamais
et
tha
plus
je
il est là
c'est
et
il
bon
en somme
e
bah